it's officially week one of Google cloud
next on air which means we're focusing
on Industry Insights
I'm Stephanie Wong and welcome to this
week in cloud where we're taking a sneak
peek of this week's contact next on air
begins tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time with Thomas Carey ins opening
keynote if you'd like to hear the CEO of
Google cloud share his insight on how
businesses can leverage Google cloud
technology then be sure to add this to
your playlist after that week one is all
about industry insights meaning we
wanted to spend the first week
emphasizing what you can do with Google
cloud for that we've got eight industry
spotlights financial services healthcare
and life sciences gaming manufacturing
media and entertainment public sector
retail and telecommunications you can
hear directly from organizations that
have built clever solutions with a
little help from Google cloud one
session that I'm particularly excited
about is reimagining public sector in
the kovat 19 era pretty much everyone
has to plan around legacy systems which
is why I love the idea of learning how
government and education institutions
adapted when faced with a global
pandemic Roberta Reardon the New York
State Department of Labor Commissioner
will join Mike Daniels our VP of global
public sector in what's sure to be an
interesting session so be sure to add it
to your playlist and don't forget to go
exploring we've done our best to bring
all the aspects of a conference floor
into this digital event so be sure to
check out the digital showcase where you
can find video demos of how Google cloud
tools can help solve the various
business challenges you may be facing
we've also got a collection of
interactive demos and even several
learning opportunities all launching
tomorrow
so have fun wandering around the website
to add these sessions to your digital
playlist check out the links in the
video description any thoughts or ideas
leave us comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you